RIGHT NOW THEY OCCUPY THE FINAL
PLAYOFF SPOT IN
ACROSS THE LINE
VERY ACTIVE.
THEY LIKE TO GET
KEEPING IT ROLLING.
ONE OF THE HOTTEST OFFENSE OF
STRAIGHT AWAY.
A TERRIFIC SET UP.
PUCKON THAT.
LOW TO HIGH. BRAKES ON.
DRIVE D. GET CLOSE TO THE NET.
MOVES IN.
A CHECECTO
PICK UP
ALREADY THIS SEASONTHE SHIFT.
ON THE DOORSTEP.
ROBERTS
A RISK SHOT IN  IT
SHOULD GO DOWN TO THE OT
ON THE POWER PLAY.
HE GETS HIS OWN REBOUND AND
THE PLAY WAS THERE BEFORE HE
GOT TO THE F THE INSIDE OF THE
IT HI  ACROSS AND
A POWER-PLAY COMING UP IN
HIS SECOND OF THE NIGHT.
HE IS SHORTHANDE GET IT
DEEP.
THE TURNOVER IS CREATED.
HE GETS A PIECE OF IT.
PENALTY ALREADY CALLED.F.
IT IS ACROSS THE
J COULD USE SOME ARREST YEAR.
TO THE REDIRECT.
TRYING TO GET AHEAD OF THE
PUCK.
PUT ON NET.